anne sylvestre tu es venu avec des
enfants as-tu les souvenirs de noël
j'ai j'ai eu dès noël alsacien parce que
maman est alsacienne et
nous avons fait le noël alsacien avec le
sapin avec
un mois avant noël déjà des bruits de
papier froissé derrière les portes ce
qui nous rend des
jumeaux frénétique et puis
et puis le sapin caché jusque jusqu'à la
dernière minute les petits paquets qui
s'amoncellent enfin pour clore tout le
folklore et puis les petits gâteaux avec
la recette bien caché je peux dire
vraiment que même aux moments les plus
jeunes et plus bizarre on n'a peut-être
pas eu toujours des choses si on est
toujours d'une des noëls ça je pense que
c'est aussi une certaine
s cut à petit il va nous chanter quelque
chose
autour du clair de la terre autant des
fusées
motors duclair de la terre qu'est ce qui
te fait rêver j'aime pas ça n'aille
j'aime dans sa note
à tout ce qui arriva à ce petit enfant
là ils étaient venus est pauvre qu'on
l'avait couché
ils étaient venus et pauvres dans la
paille des bergers mais ça l'a piqué
il devait pleurer
et son père charpentier ali pouvait lui
clouer mais les soldats à leur suite il
voulait les tuer
mais les soldats à leur suite les
forçait à se cacher je ne comprends pas
ça ne choque pas
un soldat même méchant ça ne tue pas un
enfant et qu'on voir les rois mages les
marlène tort et quand var les rois mages
lui donnèrent leurs trésors
ils auraient mieux fait
d'importer du lait
des couvertures et des draps pour qu'il
est un peu moins froid pour toi c'est
une légende kimia ii bien loin pour toi
c'est une légende
tu ne comprends pas très bien que je
comprends c'est que les méchants devrait
devenir meilleur avec noël dans le coeur
autant duclair de la terre tu as bien
compris
arie de la terre devrait bien comprendre
aussi que nos recettes
rien qu'un peu de paix
ça tout le méchant rien que tout petit
enfant d'école ce temps rien qu'un peu
d'appels
face à tous les méchants rien qu'un tout
petit enfant
[Applaudissements]
et est ce que tu
crois au père noël
comme comment tu sais que
parce que j'étais tout petit j'y croyais
n'en suit maman m'a expliqué que c'était
pas la peine que c'est pas vrai alors si
elle n'avait pas expliqué j'aurais pu y
croire toute ma vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]